à à
ừ ừ
anh alo chào các bạn
[âm nhạc]
Các bạn có vẻ hóng nghe tâm sự cái từ
đấy nhỉ Mình gì à Chắc Ai gần đây không
có tâm sự gì cả
kiểu ngồi tốt xong rồi một Chơi game còn
ngồi lại
lại Cốt nó sẽ thế
à à
à Xong rồi còn dậy đã đấy Nói chung là
cả tuần sinh hoạt mình chỉ có gắn liền
với những cái đấy thế nó chẳng có gì tâm
sự lắm tâm sự rồi Chắc là tâm sự mỗi về
chuyện Người cũ rồi
Cái đấy là cái thứ ám ảnh mình nhớ mình
nhớ nhiều nhất điều rất là ra không nên
chia sẻ người cái đấy à
anh không nên chia sẻ người cái đấy ở
trên khóa học nhạy cảm này rồi alo
à à
Có
[âm nhạc]
những mối tình cũ của mình được cái
nhiều lắm tha hồ có cái mà kể nhưng mà
thức nó không tốt cho lắm thì kéo dài
vì nó không có gì đáng tự hào hỏi cái vụ
đấy
cô bạn gái người Nhật nào nhỉ Hôm trước
có ông bờ bạn gái tôi người nhật bạn gái
tôi người Việt ông ạ Bạn ấy người Đắk
Lắk à
khi sex
khi tâm sự về người yêu mới á Ừ thôi bây
giờ đến giờ học rồi mày thế
bây bây giờ bắt đầu vào buổi họp nhé
chia sẻ kinh nghiệm yêu đương mà
ờ ờ công thức Sự thật thì nó nhà ngày
một sự thật gì à mình hẹn hò với rất
nhiều bạn rồi thì chỉ rút ra dùm cái đó
là
đương nhiên là rút ra kinh nghiện trong
chuyện tình cảm cũng nhiều nhưng mà con
gái chẳng có ai cho mày nhưng thành ra
lại
mang tiếng là có thể từng tán được một
bạn rồi không ở nghĩa với để tán được
bản khác có thể cách tương tự cái thứ
chả qua là biết cách thì giỗ biết biết
cách để mở kiểu kiểu dạng đoán xem bạn
đấy sẽ ăn gì hết để những cái mà Mấy ông
có thể đoán được để lâu trải qua nhiều
mối tình thơ ô
chữ cũng đoán cũng đoán được để xem lại
dỗi cái gì Ừ thì mày ông sẽ có kinh
nghiệm về mấy cái đấy chứ còn à hẹn hò
nhiều xong thì
chỉ có kiểu khó chịu lấy cái việc là
à
còn
có nhiều trải nghiệm hiểu mình mình
không quên đấy thế là nó không tốt lắm
ờ ờ
các bạn nóc nhà quá đấy không phải quát
mình đâu có con chó thôi đừng hiểu nhầm
Ok Bây giờ mình
đi xe Fast chia sẻ mình cuối giờ mình sẽ
trả lời câu của bạn Phương Linh kia điều
hòa cuối giờ mình sẽ trả lời cái cái đấy
nó hơi đụng chạm một tí theo góc nhìn
của mình mà cuối giờ bạn nhớ nhắc mình
sẽ trả lời cái câu của bạn làm sao đoán
được thậm chí là tôi sẽ nói làm sao đá
được con gái rồi làm sao đoán được các
bạn ơi Muốn gì nữa ờ
ở đầu tiên thì mình trả lời mấy câu Hôm
trước có bạn hỏi đó force Attack
là gì bởi vì cái cái các bạn Nhớ cái lần
mà mình nói về cái vụ hametech nghĩa là
đoạn
là kiểu kiểu dạng là kiểu mình có đeo
cặp qua vụ là sẽ có con boss nó sẽ chạy
dò dò mật khẩu trong liên tục liên tục
để khi học thành công thì thôi đúng ạ Nó
sẽ thử mọi ký tự mọi thì tự luôn nghĩa
là bao gồm cả chữ và Số kí tự đặc biệt
để mà do mật khẩu thì cái đấy chính là
pha tách
thì cài dictionary Attack nó cũng là một
kiểu dò như thế nhưng nó lại khác một tí
ở nó rò Nhưng mà theo kiểu dạng là nó sẽ
là theo tên của người dùng này nó sẽ là
từ có nghĩa Chứ không phải là tất cả các
từ và tên nói dùng kết hợp với ngày Ừ
đấy rau bằng bé ông không bao giờ nên để
tên hai ngày sinh thích nhất là của ông
cho cho mật khẩu không tốt đấy thiệu thế
a
tiếp theo hết Wow thì sang máy quê ở
thời
Anh ơi mình mình chưa chia sẻ cho mình
xin lỗi mình sẽ gọi E
Ờ Ờ cái này nó bị lỗi đấy nó bị
nó cứ mặc định là sao nó màn hình bên
này rồi nghỉ tí đi
à à
ừ
rồi rồi
anh em
ờ ờ
em hết Wow thì không có sang máy queo là
hết were gần như là các bạn kết thúc
khóa học mày luôn nên là buổi sau mình
sẽ dậy về cho Jackson và chắc là mình sẽ
à mình mình bảo là
mình sẽ thử cân nhắc về vụ là chẳng biết
buổi sau buổi xong nữa bọn mình sẽ thử
giun sẽ học quà zoom ờ ờ
ở buổi tuổi sau mình sẽ học qua room để
mà có gì còn ạ
ở đây nghe mình sẽ có quay lại video
Ờ
họ có zoom để mà mình sẽ gọi vài bạn để
nó trả lời câu hỏi vấn đáp nên là buổi
sau các bạn xác định đi đúng không ạ bữa
ô mai họp với kiến thức rất là khó em
buổi sau Thế là mùi cuối rồi ư
à
Hôm nay có bốn mấy bạn thôi à Ừ bốn mấy
bạn thử cả qua dùm cũng được đấy không
ra đâu Anh có dậy tối ưu mà cậu ashwell
không ra mình hôm trước mình có nói là
mình sẽ không dạy nâng cao cũng không
gửi không dậy kiểu và những cái bài toán
thực tế đến thế thế nên là mình mình chỉ
gợi ý các bạn rồi các bạn nếu muốn được
sự tìm hiểu thêm về thực tế là thứ nhất
là cái túi yêu cầu tối ưu ý nghĩa lắm
chỉ đạo khiến cho một câu select của các
bạn mà còn Insert update Delete
nó chạy nhanh hơn thì cái cái Insert
update Delete chạy muốn chạy nhanh ấy
thì thứ nhất ở các bạn không nên cẩu dội
à các bạn đương nhiên là một lúc Insert
update nhiều cái cùng lúc ở đây ở đây
mình mình cho các bạn xem qua nhé đây ta
sử mình nói nhanh về các vụ Insert đi
nếu mà các bạn muốn Insert anh đi xâm
Hôm trước mình đọc cái bài sơn 1 tỷ và
ghi vào bảng cùng một lúc hỏi cùng một
lúc nhà mày rớt 1 tỷ và ghi thì đương
nhiên là các bạn thứ nhất là không nên
một câu lệnh S1 câu lệnh SQL mà nhưng
xuất rễ treo chết luôn cả cái con server
chơi luôn con tơ bay để không lên các
bạn mình chia ra thì nhưng mà chia ra
thì cũng không cần phải chia đến nỗi là
kiểu in xuất từng hàng một thì 1 tỷ mất
bao lâu rồi ông ạ Các bạn sẽ phải rớt
như thế nào thì ông đấy có bài chia sẻ
nó sẽ chia theo nhóm này sau đó thì để
bể Chánh nghiệp nặng và đảm bảo giả sử
đảm bảo cơ sở liệu các bạn đúng hết rồi
theo kiểu là dữ liệu Insert vào sữa
chuẩn ấy thì các bạn không cần phải mở
cái các bạn nếu cái con trên không ạ Cái
con trên này là để mà kiểm tra cái ràng
buộc theo kiểu là nó nó phải là unique
này nó nó lu Ừ nó là khoáng ngoại nó
phải khớp này Vân Vân nó phải thông qua
hành khách này các bạn nhiều không thì
cái Giả sử dữ liệu các bạn nó rất là ổn
rất là đúng rồi Các bạn có thể bỏ qua
cái vụ còn trên này để cho thay vì cứ
Insert vào nó lại phải kiểm tra lại toàn
bộ dữ liệu xem dữ liệu đúng hay không
thì nó chỉ đơn giản là chạy Insert thôi
đúng ạ thậm chí là tắt luôn cái Index đi
cũng được bởi vì các bạn nhớ về cái vụ
hôm trước mình nói vụ Index là các bạn 7
dday vào để cho salad nhanh hơn nhưng bù
lại khi mà các bạn thay đổi dữ liệu thì
nó là phải kiểm tra
kiểm tra lại vết kết hợp với việc nó
phải cập nhật lại nét nữa Thế nên là các
bạn
nếu mà có thể các bạn tặng tắt nó đi để
mà Côi xuất các bạn chạy nhanh sau đó
các bạn hãy nhắc lại Cải Trạng cả cái
bảng cũng được thay vì kiểu cư Insert
đến đâu thì đáng bị rách lại đến đấy Nó
không cần thiết bởi vì sao Bởi vì bởi vì
chừng em muốn xe Bac ngay cái đoạn mà
các bạn kính shop thì các bạn bị đánh
đít lại đúng ạ Còn bây giờ các bạn đang
Insert liên tục liên tục mà các bạn C
lách lại cái đoạn đấy Sáng mình nghĩ là
chẳng sẽ lách lợn đấy Ăn gì đâu đúng ạ
thì các bạn thấy là 1 tỷ cái bạn ghi đấy
các bạn đáng để và kiểm tra lại inbox
các thứ thứ nó sẽ bị tốn kém thêm tài
nguyên không ạ tương tự Thế thì cái vụ
update và Delete thường là các bạn sẽ đi
kèm với cái wed đúng không ạ thì kệ wed
này quay này nó sẽ phải dựa trên những
cái cột mà đã làm Index là sử web tên
bằng gì gì đó tớ bằng lòng nhận đúng ạ
thì nếu mà Giả sử một tên tên này các
bạn mà chưa đánh lên đấy thì cái việc
wirte này nó sẽ khiến câu lệnh các bạn
sẽ chậm đi đúng không ạ Các bạn sẽ phải
đánh Intex có những cái cột đấy nhưng
cái cột mà các bạn nằm trong Where I
Ừ đấy thì cả đấy tối ưu và các bạn để
kiểm tra xem những đất có chạy được hay
không thì có bạn sẽ thêm chữ Sake kết
hợp với chữ explain ở trước như thế này
xong rồi sau đó là
là câu sẽ nách bình thường các bạn đấy
thì cái explain nó sẽ trả về cho các bạn
cái À à
Ừ cái kiểu dạng là cái con sẽ lấy rồi
các bạn nó tốn bao nhiêu bộ nhớ này xong
rồi nó có sử dụng Index 20 này nó dựa
trên những bảng nào Cột nào vẫn luôn Vân
và sẽ nó là giải thích màn không ạ thì
các bạn các bạn sẽ học cách phải học
cách đọc mình người ấy thì các bạn mới
biết tôi yêu cầu truy vấn đấy mình qua
hết mà một lượt cơ bản để các bạn biết
hướng nếu mà các bạn đang làm về bên tối
ưu nhé á
à à
ờ ờ
Cho tim mình có dự định dậy Chắc là đệ
data silde và data-analytic thì phải
Alice thì
tim mình hiện tại đang không có chính
xác là tim Chắc là bạn ý vài nói là yêu
tim và ban Nói chung nhà sẽ các thầy cô
ở bên đấy discord thì mấy thầy cô ấy như
bây giờ đang không chuyên mạnh ngay để
nó dậy các bạn
về sau rồi cháu sẽ có thôi có hàm kênh
ngày rồi mà đông ạ
Có nên để phân Trần IP tự ý bạn này chắc
là kiểu
ờ ờ
muốn để cụt mã tự động tăng đều gửi thế
kết hợp cả chữ có số người can như mình
từng nói thì cái này rồi không không thể
làm được và bên esquare và không nên làm
luôn thường công ty nào cũng thường hay
là chơi thôi cậu là dùng ngôn ngữ lập
trình để làm cái này thấy chia sẻ cách
tải tài liệu trên mấy cái trang có vài
bạn hỏi mình với vụ hôm trước có bạn hỏi
mình cách tải phim netflix hay cái tới
nào ạ sẽ các bạn sâu gồ đôi khi đối với
cả mấy cái trang giống như netflix hay
là YouTube hay Facebook ra mình cái
trắng lớn đấy thì kiểu gì cũng sẽ có rất
nhiều ông từng chia sẻ rồi bởi vì nó
quốc tế thì kiểu dìm sẽ lòi ra một vài
ông hacker có khi mấy ông hacker Trung
Quốc ông ấy cơm người Nga đấy ạ thì ông
ấy chỉ có chia sẻ về một cái tool để mà
kêu lấy được link chuẩn mà thể tải được
cái gì đó còn mấy cái trang cậu nhưng mà
bài toán thì vẫn là cha mất tiền có sẵn
mấy ông không không đòi hỏi được việc là
nếu không có thể dễ Mẹ Của Nó không
Không thì nó cần câu cơm rồi ra mở không
ạ ra sẽ biết cách để ngăn cái điều đấy ạ
a&p không làm tiện ích được
à à ý
thì cái cái cái tiết này nếu mà các bạn
học bên A bên web mình đang nói thì các
bạn sẽ thấy là một web về cơ bản nó sẽ
chạy bởi ht lcs và Sweet đúng ạ thì cái
tiện ích này bản chất nó sẽ Switch để
chạy song song cùng với web thế nên là
tiện ích nó mới viết bằng you speak thế
này là tiện ích cũng không làm được vào
bằng bất kì cái gì khác ngoài ra Switch
đâu ạ
Ừ
ok trả lời hết câu hỏi các bạn ngày hôm
trước rồi mình không Chữa bài tập bởi vì
à buổi hôm trước cả hai buổi hôm trước
đều bài tập tương đối mình thấy à Chỉ là
là lại những cái thứ mà mình đã dậy thì
thế là các bạn xem đủ lại video là cũng
làm được rồi nếu mình mới bỏ qua đâu mà
cho dù các bạn làm bài tập cũng hay đấy
Mình thấy à các bạn làm các thứ mình vẫn
sẵn là trả lời đầy đủ mà ok Nói chung ở
hôm nay đến buổi đến cái khó rồi các bạn
buổi cuối rồi đang có 59 ông hi vọng ở
tôi dậy xong buổi này Mấy ông không rụng
dần về đây sẽ buồn mình vẫn khẳng định
đây sẽ là cái khó
thì đầu tiên thì shipper là cái gì a
checker nó nếu dịch thô ra rồi nó là cò
súng theo kiểu lại cái thứ gì Nó là cái
kiểu canh ăn không biết có xúc tác dụng
ở gì không là để ngăn không cho bắn thì
phải nhớ dễ đấy thì
Ừ thì tất cả Và và nó Khánh nghiệm chế
Cơ nó sẽ khái niệm Tại sao tự nhiên tôi
nhắc cò súng đây vì nó có khác nghiệm
file recover được kích hoạt có súng cũng
mà cũng là khi kích hoạt cái cơ Cái
chích Cơ nó sẽ được kích hoạt trong ba
trường hợp
trong trong chính xác là có 3 loại cây ở
gần đấy bà loạn chị giao nhé
đó là loại Thứ nhất đó là khi cơ về rock
in tức là khi đăng nhập khi đăng nhập
xong thì sẽ kích hoạt thì chị thơ này ờ
ờ
ý thì cái loại này mình sẽ không dậy Bởi
vì thực sự nó chẳng có gì đặc sắc cả
mình sẽ Đề cập về loại thứ hai và loại
thứ ba nó sẽ là loại đầu tiên thì cái cơ
bản cái cơ bản trước nhé cái dễ trước
nha nó vào loại after I Ừ ông đoán được
cái loại
after dịch ra là gì mày không đi học à
à À còn một buổi nữa trang sức Rừng Quê
nè buổi thôi là không quan trọng đâu em
ờ
ờ Nếu không thử gì cho tôi after là gì
mà Mấy ông đoán luôn cả loại Thứ ba là
gì đi
khi bị vọng Alo
vị vọng ạ
alo alo
chưa
kể chi cầu after là sau khi ở ngoại
Thế cái loại thứ ba nó là gì
Ừ
cái loại Thứ ba là gì
không Không chơi việc là mấy ông lên sư
cái tràn tôi rồi đọc trước rồi nhé I
em
không nghe máy ông sẽ nghĩ là nó sẽ
before không ạ
Hình như có chị có sau thì anh phải có
trước đúng không em à không không không
không quên lúc đầu mình tưởng thế nó sẽ
là inter nó thay thế
Còn đây là after là sau khi lại đầu nhọn
sau khi làm cái gió thì sẽ được kích
hoạt chất xơ còn đi Speed là bảo nó thay
thế hẳn luôn cái câu lệnh Đấy bằng một
cái gì đó để không ạ Cái có bạn từng hoa
mắt mình mình bạn ấy có gặp gỡ Floor
Floor đấy
thì for nó sẽ bằng để after cũng đều bạn
là sau khi nhá đâu ạ nghĩa là về cơ bản
là mình sẽ chỉ có ba cái chị cười thôi
đừng ạ
Có trang mã mấy ông đúng không để ý gì
cả thì cao trong mô tả của tôi đang đi
cập thì chưa
Tôi để lại cái link nhé á
để
chứng tỏ Nếu không phải đọc mô tả của
tôi buồn vãi
à à
đề
thi ok Bây giờ thì để mình dậy các bạn
thì trong nhà mình vừa nói đó là không
dậy về wine mà mình sẽ dậy sau khi thi ở
đây cái sau khi ở đây mình muốn làm cái
gì Giả sử là sự nhé Ở đây có một cái bài
toán đơn giản nghe đi mình à
thì
mình sẽ
mình sẽ mở cái Excel lên cho bạn sẽ hình
dung
ta sử mình có bạn lớp và
các bạn sinh viên ở nào ạ
các
bạn sinh viên
Giả sử mình có cột mã của tên vẫn như cũ
ở đây vẫn còn mã của tên này đúng ạ Như
đỡ nhiên và sinh viên sẽ có mà lớp đông
ạ Thì hồi trước cách để mà lấy toàn bộ
sinh viên của một lớp nào đó đúng ạ thì
các bạn sẽ thấy là à mình sẽ dùng xe
lách cao form form bằng accounts for bản
sịt for bảng lớp cho ấy bạn sinh viên để
mà lấy toàn bộ sinh viên của lớp đấu
ngoãn thì thì
bây giờ mình làm theo kiểu khác khác một
tí đi để ông ạ ra xử là mình muốn lưu
lại luôn cái việc số lượng sinh viên của
một lớp ở trong một cột ở trong mảng lớp
luôn để về sau mình đỡ mỗi lần mình và
truy cập vào mình đỡ phải mất công cao
lại nó còn gì thường là nó sẽ cố định
theo năm học gì gì đó đúng ạ biểu cảm 15
gần như là nó sau khi thay đổi số lượng
sinh viên đúng ạ thì các bạn có mỗi lần
truy cập vào các bạn lại đến lại Thực ra
nó không tốt về về xử lý thế nhưng đương
nhiên mà như mình từng nói đó là liên
quan việc bài toán sai về cái dữ liệu
theo kiểu là các bạn hạn chế lưu cái cột
mà có thể tính toán từ cái dữ liệu khác
đúng ạ khi ví dụ Giả sử với ông những
thay đổi sinh viên thì đương nhiên là số
lượng nó lại thay đổi không ạ thì hôm
nay mình sẽ dạy các bạn chích cơ Để làm
thay đổi rồi đấy là sử ở đây là số lượng
sinh viên trong lớp đó ngoãn thì sẽ lưu
lên thêm cột này thì đương nhiên lúc đầu
Giả sử có một lớp nó đi đúng ạ một lớp
mã là một này làm
lớp là SQL chẳng hạn đóng ngoặc số lượng
là sông này đúng ạ Đây nghĩa là mình tạo
ra lớp này trước lớp mày đang chưa có
sinh viên nào đúng ạ Thế bây giờ Bây giờ
giả sử mình tự nhiên mình thêm một bạn
sinh viên vào chẳng hạn đúng không ạ ra
sửa mình thêm bạn Long vào cái mà lớp là
một thì có phải là bây giờ thì mình phải
hiểu là mình phải cập nhật lại cái số
lượng sinh viên này tăng lên là ờ đúng à
cho cả lớp chép Wow Giả sử đây có hai
lớp đi sử có hai lớp đi là web này
số lượng cũng là không này thì rõ ra là
bạn thấy ở đây có hai lớp nhưng mà nó
cập nhật cho lỡ nào thôi ạ cập nhật cho
mỗi lớp SQL Tại sao lại cập nhật cho mỗi
lớp em cao ạ đúng không ạ em ngủ ngon bé
ông trả lời dần dần mấy câu này dần đi
nhé Ngủ ngon thì tại sao nói cập nhật
trong mỗi lớp SV mà không phải là lớp
web à
Ê mấy ông có ăn theo kịp tôm ấy Ok bạn
Khi trả lời đầu tiên có vẻ đúng rồi
không ạ dựa theo em mà lớp bằng một đúng
ạ thì thì rõ ràng là ok ở đây giả sử
mình y rớt một bạn mới đúng không ạ thì
thì lấy cái cột mã lớp của họ đúng chưa
vậy Lấy cột mã của họ đúng không lấy cốt
mãi là nọ của nó sau đó thì bắt đầu xem
lại sao mở lớp là à với cái mã này thì
tương ứng với cái lớp nào sau đó thì cập
nhật số lượng cho họ đúng không ạ
Anh thấy bây giờ trước mắt thì tôi làm
chỉ cơ để làm cho đoạn này đã thì mới
ông hiểu nhé Ok đầu tiên tôi tạo bà đúng
không biết thấy bồ này lớp này
khi mã này in DAMtv tự động tao không ạ
bên này phải tra 50 chẳng hạn
a
marikina
mã á
em có bạn lớp rồi
ra đi cross hết đi con như nào lại hết
từ đâu
Ừ
để chắc là thôi Về Đó Chắc mình sang hẳn
cái tem thêm tay Mày biết tao ở Pari này
tạm thời PB này mình làm cái gì xong cái
này thì khi mắt cái nổi thì hình như là
cái cái dữ liệu nó sẽ bị xóa thành ra là
mình hoàn toàn bộ sau không bị ảnh hưởng
bụi trước cũng được đấy Giả sử là bây
giờ mình cắt in such trước hai lớp nhá
lớp này á đông Nhầm nhầm nhầm thiếu cột
kiểu cột và rồi cho thấy bồ lớp này chưa
có thể enter nó cũng được nhưng mình
đang muốn làm nhanh
số lượng sinh viên không ạ số lượng sinh
viên đi tạm bỏ qua trách chùm các thử
nhé sự là cũng hiểu là số lượng sinh
viên nó không được ăn mày cứ thử đi Mình
sẽ để defo là không đi thì thôi là không
đúng
ở nhà lúc đầu chưa sinh viên nào đúng
không ạ sử mình có tên này
và lu nó này
là espier này sau đó đi web đúng không ạ
web này là sự đang có hai lớp đúng không
ạ sau đó thì snack sao for love
sau đó thì các bạn sẽ thấy là ok bây giờ
đang có
em đang có hai lớp đúng số lượng sinh
viên là không đúng rồi đúng không ạ Bây
giờ mình tạo bàn tiết thì tạo bảng sinh
viên không ạ sinh viên này
mì đây mình sẽ thay đây là mà lớp này
kiểu gì nè sau đó thì đương nhiên là có
khóa ngoại ràng buộc cho nó chắc đi còn
kỳ mà lớp này
lớp tại cột mã sản ạ ạ
à à
Em nói đi này khi bây giờ giả sử mình
Insert into sinh viên nhá tên này mã lớp
đúng không ạ
ba lô là Long
và lớp thứ nhất đúng ạ chạy thử này
ạ sau đó Thì bây giờ mình sẽ select sao
cả lớp này Các sinh viên à à
thì chả như này các bạn sẽ thấy là ở đây
ở đây sinh viên cập nhật vào trong lớp
đúng rồi không đi sai cả nhưng số lượng
của sinh viên của cả lớp mà mới thêm vào
đúng không ạ thì số lượng nó vẫn bằng
không thế là sai rồi khô ngọn tích trong
trường hợp này khi mình cần làm như thế
nào mình cần là một có một cái gì đó tác
động cập nhật lại số lượng tự động tự
động nhé nghĩa là cứ mỗi lần hơn sinh
viên mới thì nó phải tức động cập nhật
lại số lượng thì nó mới đúng đúng không
ạ
Ừ
nếu mà bộ hôm nay mà dạy chơi cờ mỗi cái
chích girl after mà mà chưa xong thì
mình chắc chắc là phải mất cả một buổi
sau nữa từ buổi sau dậy cả chích cơ khí
xếp hợp cũng được kết hợp với Trang sẽ
dừng cũng được nghỉ buổi sao bạn ơi thế
bởi vì riêng chứ Cô ấy rất dài nếu không
có tập trung nghe và tại thì
ạ Bây giờ mình cập nhật số lượng nó sẽ
như sau mình sẽ phạm cái cơ hạ điệp khúc
Trap này chị cơ này cho tên của vị trí
cơ này là thêm sinh viên em ạ
tôi không đùa với ông đâu nó khó lắm
sống dựa trên cục trên bảng vì nó sẽ quy
ước thẳng và trên bạn vì luôn nó là sự
trên mạng sinh viên này và tiếp theo đó
là cái kiểu của nó là kiểu gì kiểu đấy
là kiểu after không ạ Và
à mà tiếp theo đó nữa là mình phải dựa
trên kết cái phương thức gì phương thức
Insert update Delete sẽ có 3 phương thức
để mà tạo chị cơ 3 phương thức bml các
bạn nếu đ m n là data
mandu pilation high school net gì đấy
many full Lysine và thật là cậu chi phối
ngôn ngữ chi phối dữ liệu cái kiểu thế
nó sẽ là Insert update Delete
tái chế Cơ nó sẽ chạy trên cái dml dựa
trên ba cái này thì với ở trong trường
hợp này là in sơ đồ ngoại mình sẽ dựa
trên in shop này
này BV này em này đề
thi cái bài toán ở đây thì như mình vừa
nãy nói lại phải quay lại cái xem một tí
ạ như vừa nãy mình nói là bây giờ mình
thêm một bạn sinh viên mới này ra xử mã
bạn để con 10 đi đừng ạ thì rõ ràng là
các bạn vẫn sẽ hiểu mã của bạn này Bây
giờ thì ra nó không quan trọng gì cả
đúng ạ
a mã bạn ấy đã không hề quan trọng mà mã
bạn này mã lớp của bạn đấy mới quan
trọng mình sẽ phải lấy cột mã lớp này
sau đó thì mình Cập nhật lại mình tìm
phải không bảo đó xem là cái mã nào phù
hợp với các bạn lớp đấy hội cập nhật Số
lượng số lượng bây giờ phải cầm điện lên
mấy ạ lên 10 ạ phòng nhật lên mày á
thì các bạn cứ trả lời mình dần dần đi
rồi rồi các bạn sẽ hiểu tại sao mình hỏi
mấy câu kiểu hiển nhiên như thế
nó lên mấy nó lên mười nó lên hai nó lên
1 lên 10 ạ Ok các bạn sẽ hiểu ở Ok Bây
giờ nó lên 1 đó giả sử bây giờ sự tại
thêm một bạn nữa Bạn tên Tuấn em ạ lại
cũng mã lớp là một thì thì bây giờ nó sẽ
như thế nào ạ
ạ bây giờ phải thay đổi với chị ạ Hãy Cứ
thế thôi
Ừ ông kia lên 10 thật kìa có lên là hai
cái gì lên là 2 Nếu quan trọng cái gì
lên là hai cái này lên là hai hai cái
này lên là 2a
Ừ đúng rồi bạn kia nói cái bạn trái
nhưng không khét kia Bạn này nói mới
chuẩn kìa
các bạn nó nói dùng lực cộng một nó mới
chuẩn không không Đừng có phân biệt 2 2
3 4 tỷ đây cả đúng ạ ạ ạ
Ừ cái cái ý mình mong muốn muốn hỏi đây
thứ nhất đó là các bạn phải giữ giải mã
lớp để cập nhật cho thằng này hai thằng
này đúng ạ và phải lấy cái số lượng sinh
viên cũ và tăng nó lên cộng một chứ
không phải ghét nó bằng hai luôn bởi vì
như bạn vừa nói là tăng lên là hai thì
ok bạn đã hiểu nó lên là hay nhưng mà
bây do các bạn biết đến các bạn thấy ở
đây có một ít sinh viên thì các bạn đang
đếm được thì các bạn vào hai bây giờ sử
bây giờ mình yên tâm phần trăm sinh viên
đây thì các bạn không đến được nó là bao
nhiêu đây đúng ạ thì các bạn sẽ phải
hiểu lại cứ thêm một bạn sinh viên nạp
vào thì lấy số lượng sinh viên cũ + lên
em Treo mạ lớp đúng rồi bạn tiền là đúng
rồi theo mã lớp thì nó mới chuẩn
Ừ đúng ạ
thì ở đây để làm đơn giản chưa các bạn
thì bây giờ mình cứ mình bây giờ để mà
mình có cái chích ga này bây giờ nhớ cậu
nhớ con này của tôi nha Cái gì chỗ hỏi
vấn đáp hỏi câu này à à chích cơ một khi
nó chạy bất kỳ cơ
bất kỳ cơ Insert update Delete một khi
nó chạy nó sẽ luôn có hai bạn được sinh
ra đều ạ nó bản chất thật và bạn đi
lasted
bảng Asus tin tức là lưu lại những cái
cái thông tin mà các bạn sẽ in search
trước khi mày Insert vào trong bảng viết
tên cũng thế thôi đó là là lưu lại thông
tin các bạn sẽ Delete trước khi chạy có
Delete thì
Ờ Ờ bây giờ để mà muốn lấy cái mã lớp
của một bạn giả sử cái bạn lo vừa rồi
đúng ạ mình giả sử mình chữ Insert vào
trong trong bảng trong bảng sinh viên
vội chim à chích girl chạy ạ Bây giờ các
bạn đang hiểu là chị có after đ
à À đúng rồi chết rồi after nghỉ ngựa
chạy xăng xử rồi không ạ nhưng mà vẫn
thấy được từ cái bản in xuất thật nha
mặt lấy được từ bài xuất Tuy rằng nó
chạy Xong rồi chuyện cái after là chị cơ
chạy Xong sự A chạy sau khi mà in sẽ
Xong rồi mày không ạ Mình vẫn lấy lại từ
bản in sẽ tập được và mình sẽ lấy cái mã
lớp của cái thằng sinh viên đấy để mà
Cập nhật lại xong mạng lớp
đây sẽ như sau ra xử mình có sẽ lexar
for instant để các bạn sẽ hình dung đã
chạy thử này
ạ Bây giờ giả sử mình Insert lại các bạn
sinh viên kia đúng ạ Thế mình đi xét lại
nhé ạ
vì thế các bạn sẽ thấy là nó tự động xe
lách luôn sẽ lách luôn Đúng cái mà bạn
mình gửi anh sắp đâu ạ nó sẽ tự động đi
sớm à sẽ lách lại luôn nhé Mình không
cần cái thứ mình không cần là cái này mà
mình cần lấy mỗi mã lớp thôi đúng không
ạ Rồi mình Cập nhật lại mã lớp thì đây
nó sẽ khái niệm này các bạn sẽ gán biến
cho nó bị sẽ có khái niệm và đi clip
gà nó nóng hổi biến là sửa mình đặt tên
biển mà lớp kiểu y là bằng này
snacks mã love
from instant như này thì tại sao tự
nhiên mình ở đề cập với cái biển mã lớp
ở đây làm gì bởi vì như mình vừa nói đó
là mình sẽ phải cập nhật lại bảng lớp
theo cái cột mã lớp không phải là cập
nhật cho lớp bằng hai và cập nhật theo
cho đúng cái cột mà lớp đẩy đồng loại và
số lượng nó sẽ tăng được ạ thì ở đây sẽ
khái niệm như này nó là update lớp sét
Ai Cập nhật cho cột số lượng sinh viên ở
ông ạ bằng số lượng sinh viên cũ + lên
một Where mã bằng mã lớp như thế này ông
mà không thích khai bão biển thì ông có
thể hai cái đoạn này bằng cái này cũng
được không ghi sai cả nhưng mà nhưng mà
tôi khuyên là cứ làm như này nhìn nó rõ
làm tượng Minh đã đúng không ạ Đấy Và
nếu các bạn thích thì các bạn thể giống
như kiểu vô sadda ý là các bạn hoàn toàn
thể
select Sao lại Xem lại nhìn nó tiện đúng
không ạ Đấy bây giờ bởi vì bây giờ các
bạn xem mà thấy là bây giờ thứ nhất là
số lượng sinh viên lên rồi mà số lượng
Đây nó đang như thế này thì nó hơi sai
đúng ạ Thì bây giờ mình sẽ
thì mình sẽ tạm Delete nó đi đã
đi lấy thẻ không ạ form sinh viên à
mình cứ xóa trước đi đã sao mình cứ tạo
jesica này
anh ở đây nó sẽ bảo lỗi là chị thơ này
đã được tạm rồi thì cách 2 của mình mình
nhớ mình toàn dậy các bạn về cái vụ là
mình dốt còn đi rồi quết lại đúng ạ Như
hôm trước mình thấy có cái hay có một
cái hay này press enter đây đó là đó là
thêm hoặc thay thế Cái này khá là tiện
này để đỡ mất công dốt cứ chạy cái này
là được ok bây giờ sử Mỹ đi sót lại các
bạn xem này đó thì nó sẽ cập nhật số
lượng cho cho đúng bảng lớp về thôi đúng
ạ Mình chạy lại lần nữa này đó thì nó sẽ
tăng lên thôi Bởi vì sao Bởi vì số lượng
sinh viên thay đổi mà mình mình thử xe
khách cả sinh viên cho bạn dễ nhìn nhé
mà mình quét lại phát nữa này Đấy mình
chạy lại
ở đây mình đang có 3 sinh viên ở trong
lớp SQL đúng không ạ thì nó sẽ tăng dần
dần dần lên đúng không ạ
đoạn đến đoạn này mấy ông có tài chứ
ở đoạn này không hẳn là khó hiểu lắm
đúng không Chỉ là lấy cái cột mã lớp của
của cái cái bạn sinh viên định Thêm vào
cho cập nhật số lượng đúng ạ
ở cái đoạn này thì chắc là các bạn hiểu
rồi có thể kiến thức nó hơi mới ví thôi
đúng không ạ Đúng rồi bạn kia đang hỏi
cái câu chuẩn kìa in rất nhiều sinh viên
thì nó khó nghiệp Nhưng mà cái này chưa
chưa chưa chưa tôi vẫn chưa dậy cứ bình
tĩnh bình tĩnh thưởng gì Thượng sẽ dạy
mày ông về cái vụ là in rất nhiều bạn
cùng một lúc thì nó sẽ như thế nào
Okay đến đoạn này thì các bạn thấy quá
tải chị ạ chưa ông ạ Dễ mà Dễ hiểu mà
đúng không ạ Ok bây giờ đến đoạn khó hơn
này Thế bây giờ giả sử tôi đi lết một
bạn khỏi cái lớp đấy thì số lượng đó
thay đổi không ạ
I Delete một bạn sinh viên khỏi cả lớp
đấy ra xưởng bạn kia bị đuổi học chẳng
hạn đúng ạ là sự bạn một trong ba bạn
này bị đuổi học là xử thế kiểu mạng hoặc
là do là cô giáo thêm nhầm Bạn này hay
phát nên là xóa bớt mà bạn đi thì rõ
ràng số lượng sinh viên nó phải thay đổi
đúng không ạ
Ừ đúng chưa Thì cái này cũng có thể áp
dụng chích Ơ được đúng ạ thì mình sẽ
phải cập nhật lại cái số lượng thôi
ờ
ờ đúng rồi bạn kia nói đúng đấy có - 1
lấy từ bảng đĩa cực quá chuẩn luôn nó
đúng đấy đầu tiên tôi thử vụ thêm thử
vạn sinh viên và rốt thứ hai mấy ông
thấy vẫn lên được không ạ nhưng bây giờ
là sự tôi xóa cái bạn bạn một bạn sinh
viên đi đúng không ạ thì mình cần làm ở
đây là gì thì như tội như tôi vừa nói đó
là sự thôi xóa cái bạn Thứ 5 này chẳng
mã bằng 5 này chả bạn không ạ thì lại
phải lấy cột mã lớp từ bạn biết thật sau
đó thì lại Cập nhật lại số lượng thôi
cái đoạn này thì các bạn nó tương đối dễ
nó giống hệt hàng ngày đây mình sẽ thử
chỉ các bạn nó giống hệt như nào đây
thay Sói đúng ạ Để Delete này cũng lấy
cột mã lớp nhưng mà lần này từ bạn biết
thực này sau đó cập nhật số lượng này
hai cái này ở - 1 thôi thế này xong rồi
chạy thử nhé Ừ nhanh đúng ạ Đây Delete
from sinh viên Này
Where mã bằng 5 đúng không ạ
anh rõ thế xong rồi đúng không ạ ạ
Ừ Ok cái này vẫn là dễ vẫn là dễ giờ lại
khó lên một tí này
ở belem chín mấy ông được Tại sao càng
càng khó càng thêm nhiều này Ok hãy nghe
tiếp nhé bây giờ xử là
Ừ cái bạn Long có mã là bố này đi đúng ạ
bạn đấy lại đổi sang lớp thứ hai giờ xử
bạn thích quét hơn thích Maxwell đã đổi
sang lớp thứ 2 thì cái bài toán ở đây nó
lại phức tạp hơn đúng ạ Nó lại mình phải
cập nhật lại số lượng không những ở một
lớp mà mình phải cầm được số lượng loại
2 lớp đúng hạn thì rõ ràng mà ta sử bạn
này đổi sang bạn ạ nắp bếp mã lớp sang
lớp thứ 2 đúng hạn thì rõ ra mà cái lớp
thứ nhất bạn đấy phải trừ số lượng đi
đúng ạ và lớp thứ hai bạn phải + số
lượng lên nhưng mà bệt để nói theo kiểu
theo dữ liệu như thế thì ở đây nói theo
kiểu khác thì nó sẽ nhà phải lấy cái bạn
mà thay đổi thông tin nữa ngoan Lấy cột
mã lớp cũ của bạn đấy để mà cấp để mà -
cái số lượng lớp
- số lượng sinh viên theo cả mã lớp xe
tải phím cho mình phải đi tiên à Lấy mã
lớp
à cũ này đúng ạ sau đó thì cập nhật số
lượng
sinh viên
- một theo mã lớp cũ chuẩn đi ạ
ạ sau đó Đương nhiên là cũng phải lấy mã
lớp mới đúng ạ Đấy mà lớp mới này
sau đó thì lại cập nhật số lượng sinh
viên + 1
em Treo mạc lớp mới
thì Dạo này mấy ông hiểu ạ vừa nói xong
chúng ta phải 90 dặm 180 rồi à
Ừ dạo này sao mày không hiểu lắm ạ Thế
là mình khi mình update update đổi sinh
viên đúng không ạ
anh
không bạn bạn kia đã nói việc cập nhật
nhiều sinh viên cùng một lúc cái đấy tôi
vẫn chưa chưa chưa Dậy chưa Dậy chưa Dậy
chưa Dậy à
A và
Ừ để không cho Insert một cái gì đó
chính là buổi sau sẽ học đều ạ
ê ê
Ừ bắt đầu khói không ạ thì ở đây ở đây
thì cái vụ đúng rồi bạn kia nói rất đúng
cũng cùng lúc Insert + Delete chính là
update Đúng rồi đấy ạ nghĩa để lấy được
cái mã lớp cũ và thì mình sẽ lấy từ bảng
Dell Asus còn lấy mãn lớp mới thì sẽ từ
bản in xác thực để bọn họ sẽ như này
flash chơi cờ
chỉnh
sửa sinh viên em ạ
on sinh viên
Tôi có thể copy nhà mà tôi Gõ lại cho
mấy ông đỡ quá tải đấy Thiệu vẫn còn bắt
sóng theo kịp được gì nè
đi Cola này mã love cũ
kiểu y nóng bằng bắt buộc phải có một
trò này mới nhận nhé bởi vì đấy cậu sẽ
lách salad mã love
for selected Ừ cái bảng đĩa thật này bản
chất cái bảng này nó sẽ dựa theo cái
bảng này để biết được nó có bao nhiêu
cột và cột đấy còn gì nếu vào giờ sử đây
là bạn bạn lớp đúng ạ thì cái bạn nên
tật này nó sẽ có một mã và một tên của
bạn lớp con bạn sinh viên thì sẽ có một
mã tên và mã lớp Theo bạn sinh viên thôi
đi sẽ update
lớp xét số lượng sinh viên bằng số lượng
sinh viên - một
cộng một Đúng rồi - 1 - 1 Where mã bằng
mã lớp cũ đúng ạ Cái tiếp theo mình lại
copy cái này và thay Đây là bạn lớp mới
đúng hoặc một lớp mới
anh ở đây mình sẽ là forty sự thật thì
đây sẽ là cộng 1
khi bé dựa theo một lớp mới
ông có thể select sao From A
ừ ừ
I
love
where mã lốp
mã bằng mã lớp cũ
anh ở đây mặt lớp mới thầy sửa ông ông
xem lớp cũ trước ở lớp mới sau đó đi xem
lại thằng mình vừa thằng mình vừa thay
đổi nó là gì cũng được đổ mặt tùy
tôi lại Bây giờ mình có thể lấy à sao
phone bí tịch được
hôm bia tức này và Sir Alex sao for
instance chẳng hạn để các bạn biết được
là
A chạy
ạ bây giờ xử tử cỡ Xem sinh viên trước
nhé xem thử sinh viên này
xem xem lại một lần lỡ choáng nhé bậm
vào năm đây
ừ ừ
ở bảng này rõ lớp apple đang có hai bạn
sinh viên không ạ Cái thằng Mạnh nó bằng
4 này Bây giờ mình sẽ đổi nó sang đất
thứ hai không ạ thì sẽ là update sinh
viên này xét mã lớp bằng
à à bằng hai đúng không ạ Where
mã bằng 4 chạy này
em có bạn sẽ ra như thế này lớp cũ này
thay đổi số lượng sinh viên bị giảm đi
đúng ạ đây sau đó thì lớp mới tăng lên
đúng không ạ Đầu tiên thì bạn cũ bạn
đang ở trong lớp đầu xong rồi bạn đổi
sang lớp thứ hai có ông sẽ bảo là thế
này giả sử là do sử là tự nhiên tôi
update tên của bạn đấy thôi thằng ạ quay
em ạ Không không up lên mà lớp thì nó có
lỗi gì không nó ạ sử đề lắm Hai ạ Cái
như này Thực ra nó không lỗi gì cả Chẳng
lỗi gì cả bạn đấy vẫn sẽ ở nguyên lớp
đấy đương nhiên là cái này nó hơi nhược
điểm một tí nó phải nó nó cập nhật lại
cái số lượng đấy ạ Các bạn nếu để ý kĩ
gì nó vẫn chạy cái Cập nhật lại số lượng
vẫn sẽ
i - 1 sau đó đi đó lại cộng lại một cái
câu lệnh update của các bạn khi mà các
bạn học về cái chiếc nơ này rồi các bạn
sẽ hiểu bản chất cái update nó luôn là
delete đi rồi nó yên xuất lại chứ nó
không có sửa Cột nào đó bất kỳ đâu ạ
cháu rồi các bạn rõ ràng đi Ở đây rõ
ràng tôi sửa mỗi cột tên thôi đúng ạ
nhưng mà không nó vẫn Xoay xóa toàn bộ
đi rồi nó in xuất bạn thế nên là ở đây
vẫn đang làm theo lưu dịch nó vẫn sẽ
chạy đâu mà chỉ cơ nó vẫn sẽ được cái
hoạt đúng ra sự đã đổi tên của bạn đấy
các thứ thứ
Ê mấy ông đấy lại có tại chưa
anh đã bị choáng chưa
cha mẹ ông chắn hết thoáng chưa để tôi
gián tiếp
Ừ cái vẫn là dễ đấy ngày xưa khó đâu
ừ ừ
vì
số lượng sinh viên lại giảm đi cái mền
cái khó giả
em vẫn chưa đúng không Ok ông kia bạn
chưa thì chứng tỏ là chơi tiếp thôi bây
giờ Xanh bài toán khó hơn ông kia vậy
nói là việc là Insert nhiều sinh viên
của một lúc đúng ạ Tại sao tự nhiên phải
đề cập cụ đấy Ở đây bởi vì ra sự là đây
là sự tô Insert Long hacker này và Tuấn
hacker này à
chú chạy này nó sẽ bảo lỗi các bạn thấy
báo lỗi ở đây nó liên quan các bạn sẽ
không hiểu cái này lắm Cái này nó bảo
trả về một à nhiều hơn một chị cái đoạn
lỗi này nó đương nhiên là liên quan đến
chi cơ mình vừa tạo Nó chỉ cơ Insert
sinh viên rồi thêm sinh viên này và nó
lỗi chính là lỗi tại cái câu này chỉ các
bạn sẽ thấy ở đây ạ
Ừ Cái lỗi này
ở Hà Đông một phần ạ Để đợt Đợi tí như
cậu in sơ của tôi phần vừa rồi sai vậy
Phải mà lớp ở đây đã mặt đất không được
địa chấm Xin lỗi nhé bạn lớp đây đều là
một đi và sự đều cho bạn đấy vào lớp và
một đi chạy này nó vẫn lộn cứ nhiên là
vẫn lỗi thôi Bởi vì À đây giả sử đang
còn cho cùng bằng lớp nó ngoác tí còn
tôi còn cho vào cùng và hai lớp nó còn
khó nữa cơ cùng và một lớp trước nha
mình định nhé cùng nhằm Bảo Lâm chưa
nghe thì
sau khi mà các bạn nghĩ rất nhiều sinh
viên cùng nhóm lớp như này thì nếu mà sẽ
AK sao bạn lớp borey rất thật như này có
bạn sẽ thấy à Nó trả về nó trả về hay
hai dòng chứ không phải một dòng đây
mình sẽ cho bạn xem
ạ Bây giờ mình đưa nha Bây giờ mình sẽ
sửa cái này đúng không ạ Mình sẽ hết cái
này
anh xóa tôi xóa hết cả các bạn này đi
nhé thực sự Cái đoạn này không chạy nữa
rồi xóa đi Này xóa luôn cả này đi này
tôi sẽ Shake for instant kể cho Bống xem
nhé Nếu chỉ cần xem lại thôi đợi chạy
chạy lại này
a Battle in short này trẻ này
khi đôi nha bây giờ mấy ông thấy à ý sắp
thành công rồi
cài á
chữ cái bảng cái bảng cái lớp này chưa
được cập nhật số lượng đó làm tạm bỏ qua
tạm bỏ qua điều này đi
Ê mấy ông thấy rõ ràng là cái việc khi
mà yên sơ vào thì các bạn insisted đây
là bản in xuất tuần này tôi đang thổi
cho tôi xóa luôn cả vụ snack hai cái bạn
kia đi cho bé ông dễ nhìn đây chỉ có mỗi
xe lách bả đi sự thật đây nhá này
Ừ nếu thấy rõ ràng và
sau khi mà yên shop nhiều bản ghi ở cùng
một lúc đúng ạ thì các bạn sức tận này
nó trả về cái cột mà lớp mà trả về tận
nhiều giá trị thế nên làm nếu không khai
báo đây kiểu mã lớp kiểu in kiểu là lão
chỉ chứa một giá trị và một số duy nhất
thôi đúng không thế này chả phải tận hai
số rồi bây giờ cả hai số đều số 1 nhưng
mà nó vẫn là hai số thành ăn nó báo lỗi
đúng ạ thì bây giờ thực tế và đây là
mình không cần khai báo về không Không
cần phải khai báo cái biến làm gì nữa
không cần biến mã lớp là gì nữa mình cần
ở đây là gì
anh giống như bạn kia đang nói cũng rất
đúng đó là mình phải đến đúng không ạ
Mình sẽ đến sen lớp nào có bao nhiêu
lượng sinh viên nó nó nó là như kiểu
ngay Giả sử tôi đến tôi để mua nhé tạm
bỏ qua cột mã vừa quần mà không quan
trọng mình ra sự là bây giờ tôi có như
này
thế này
Ừ thì các bạn giả sử tôi nshop không
không quan trọng mấy cục này Này nhá
Đúng không mấy cốc này được không có
nghĩa gì cả đúng ạ Bây giờ tôi là số lỗi
Insert như thế này khi mấy ông có thể
biết được ngay ok là lớp lớp có mã bằng
10 ạ thì mình sẽ thêm bao nhiêu bao
nhiêu sinh viên ạ ạ và lớp thứ 2 thì
thêm bao nhiêu sinh viên ạ đúng không ạ
đã sửa tôi một công ty Shop ở tôi rất là
này cái thì béo phải đếm hoạn Nếu sẽ đến
dựa theo cái gì không ạ Nếu không đến sẽ
là dùng hàm cao là đúng ạ cao đến màn
không ạ rồi ông đến dựa theo cái gì ông
đến dự anh em á lớp đúng ạ nghĩa là cao
như này thì mình sẽ đến được à Ok đây có
3 bạn sinh viên sẽ vào lớp 12 bạn sinh
viên sẽ vào lớp 2 chuẩn đi ạ
Mày không hiểu được là ông ấy
Alo ạ
thì các bạn sẽ đến đúng ạ và các bạn sẽ
dbow theo cái mã lớp dùng hàm cao này
bài thằng bạn lớp này sau đó thì
cái bản thân cái kosala đấy nó sẽ sinh
ra gần như sinh ra được một cái bạn đúng
không ạ đây nó sẽ như thế này để tôi tôi
copy hẳn trên này xuống trông dễ nhìn
nhé ạ
ở
đây mình sẽ là cao này
sao cũng được giúp bye bạn lớp này chuẩn
chưa Có vừa chạy cho công xem nhé
Anh Bum
ở đâu ạ
Sao mở lớp đúng mà
khi sex
à Anh nhầm rồi bye xin lỗi à
các bạn sao tự nhiên thấy báo lỗi
em chạy lại mà
ở đó nhưng nếu không thấy thấy mày Ông
thấy là tiểu nó ra đúng không ạ bây giờ
xử mình lấy thêm cuộn mã lớp nữa cho nó
cho nó chuẩn này
bây giờ sự đàn mình thêm một bạn nữa là
bạn Linh hacker này
ở lớp thứ hai cả em ạ
ở đó thì mới ông sẽ thấy là
ok ở đây sẽ là
một lớp ra rồi số lượng sinh viên ra rồi
đúng không ạ Bây giờ mình cần làm là gì
thì sẽ cần cập nhật lại từng lớp treo
cái cái mã lớp tương ứng đúng ạ và số
lượng mày sẽ là cộng và cái số lượng cũ
của cải lớp lớp đấy Đúng là được cái hợp
lý đúng không Thì mình sẽ dùng do thôi
đúng không ạ Mình sẽ cho cái này bản
chất cả cái này nó tính là một bảng xong
mình sẽ roi vào thằng kia thì đoạn này
với Bắt đầu thấy não này cái đoạn này
mình sẽ kết hợp khá nhiều cái vợ các bạn
sẽ thấy nó hơi bị hay nào vì tớ tia các
bạn cần update đúng không ạ Các bạn thân
đã bếp bảng gì bằng lớp đúng không ạ Ok
update tạm lớp này đúng ạ
Ừ nhưng mà mạng lớp này nó không nó phải
do I với cái này dựa theo cái gì rồi
theo quần mã lớp này đúng không ạ
thì mình sẽ là tên của Cao sao này là số
lượng sinh viên mới nhá
Đây mình sẽ
khái niệm như thế này
mình sẽ roi cái thang này
rồi Cả cái thằng to này thằng to mày
mình sẽ tên là ác mình sẽ đặt tên cho nó
là tê ạ
Anh hỏi em đi thay Insert đi đó
xe khách để mà cái khái niệm update your
ý thì để mình không ngờ lắm đâu Anh sẽ
tra
cho các bạn xem update cho thì
anh sex sex
v-app cho server
cài đặt các bạn sẽ thấy vẫn sẽ có xét
như bình thường và form như bình thường
và cho như bình thường như thế này không
ạ chia đây nó sẽ là hết date lớp này xét
số lượng sinh viên này bằng số lượng
sinh viên cũ này cộng với số lượng sinh
viên mới
nhà
tư bản y như thế này sau đó mình sẽ có
form lớp rồi với cả cụm này
on love chấm mã bằng y chấm mã lớp
ở đây để đoạn này thì bài nào rồi nè nó
sẽ đầy đủ như thế này
Ừ nhưng mà để để cho các bạn đã thấy nó
phức tạp như thế này mình cứ làm cho các
bạn đơn giản trước đi mình thay vì chạy
câu update này vụ những ngày cho các bạn
đỡ cho ám mình sẽ lấy trước bây giờ các
bạn xem đã nhé Mình xin lỗi tự nhiên cho
bạn những ko update nhẹ Thoáng Qua
ơi mình tạm vứt nó rằng cái file nhá
thì mình sẽ à
a snack sharefrom lớp này
rồi à
10 cái đoạn này công nhận xóa thật đoạn
này nó nâng cao mà tôi bảo đoạn này nâng
cao giống Nếu về ông thực sự mà không
một ngay nâng cao thì mấy ông phải có
thể dừng đưa cô được thì toàn bộ đấy
trên là đủ kiến nước của các bạn cơ bản
về cơ
chế cơ bản after lỗi con đến đoạn này nó
phải nâng cao để mà áp dụng cho việc in
xuất nhiều ai Dielac nhiều update nhiều
thì bắt buộc phải làm cái kiểu như này
ở đây là bạn thân là các bạn cần Đây
mình sẽ Copy lại câu truy vấn vừa rồi
đúng ạ
select này ừ ừ
em ăn gì nè và mình đã tên nó lại ra à
đúng ạ đi sẽ on
lớp trầm mã bằng y chậm mà lớp
Em nói như này à
ừ ừ
để mình thử xuất lại chọn sẽ nhá đó
đây thì các bạn sẽ thấy da bảng lớp đây
đúng số lượng sinh viên cũ đấy bảng Đây
là cái thứ sẽ tốt đấy không ạ
Bạn này khi mà Selection này Các bạn
nhìn thấy biết được luôn mà đúng ạ Các
bạn sẽ thấy nó không hẳn là khó hiểu lắm
đâu chẳng qua là cái câu lệnh này mới
rồi
cái cái cái câu lệnh này thì mình khẳng
định nó mới thì nó các bạn cái có tại
đúng không sao phải chuyện này chuyện
bình thường như là cái đoạn này các bạn
có thể thì dung được là select này các
bạn vừa gió hiểu đúng ạ sẽ lách này vừa
rồi các bạn hiểu các bạn cho lại cho lại
này các bạn vẫn hiểu mà đúng ạ thì nó
xảy ra được thông tin như này thôi đúng
ạ Thì bây giờ mình cần là gì mình cần
cập nhật cái số lượng này cộng với cái
số lượng này là xong đúng ạ
ngoạn thì bây giờ nó sẽ ra nó sẽ là câu
ấp đất này thôi thì sẽ update
ở mình kia mình do như này mình phải
khai báo ra mình sẽ biết cái bảng gì đó
ngọn gái có 2 bàn là bảo lớp rồi bằng y
là bạn ý sức thật Mình không cần bởi cập
nhật bản in sắc thật của bọn mình cần
nhận bạn lớp thôi và mình cần cập nhật
cái cột số lượng sinh viên của bạn lớp
bằng số lượng sinh viên cũ đúng ạ cộng
với số lượng sinh viên mới từ cái bảng y
ông ạ xong rồi dựa trên cái câu C của
mình vừa select là được cái thuê chạy
thôi
Em à mình cứ sẽ Rex said for love và
selects
sao form sinh viên để các bạn dễ hình
dung nhé Giả sử là bây giờ mình cứ
anh ấy thực ra mình khó chịu ở cái vụ
này Đợi mình tí mình khó chịu cái vụ đó
mã lớp đang tự động tăng này
ạ Bây giờ mình đi xuất lại Bây giờ mình
đang muốn delete toàn bộ lớp cũ đi để mà
bởi số lượng sinh viên Nãy giờ đang bị
quá tải nữa rồi Các bạn để ý kĩ là sinh
viên Nãy giờ nó cứ tăng như thế này Mà
mà trong cái đó Nãy giờ mình để
số lượng như này thành sai đúng không ạ
Bây giờ mình cần nắp lại đi
thôi áp đấy được gặp đấy lớp
xét số lượng sinh viên bằng không này
sau đó thì bị lép for love và phòng sinh
viên thế này nhanh nhỉ
I have bây giờ đi lễ rồi Có khi nó bị -
Đúng rồi Delete nó bị - dealer trước này
à
em bán Delete nó lỗi nó rồi vì cái câu
chi cơ kia đúng ạ Thế ăn tôm đấy thế nên
mình mới đang bảo là thì cứ tạm mà
lốp hẳn hai bạn hãy đi mình dốt và sinh
viên
mí rớt lại từ đầu đi coi như mình làm
lại từ đầu nhé
cô sinh viên này lốp thấy bồ hội lớp này
cách tạo loại này
anh nhìn xa lạ này để tại sao mình ở mắt
tôi rất lại này bởi vì cho một mã mã lớp
bằng mồ thôi mà lớp bằng một bằng hai
cho dễ
Ừ ok đang có bạn lớp ở sinh viên này
đang trống trơn chứ có gì không ạ
thế này Ừ ok rồi đó ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ
tạo một cái chích cơ thêm sinh viên này
đúng ạ
ở đó bơ mình di sót lại này
ở
các loại ngon không ạ
Ừ thế xong rồi đấy Đó là các bạn đã hiểu
đã biết qua được cái việc làm khi sắt
nhiều sinh viên cùng 1 lúc thì nó sẽ cập
nhật cho tương ứng với bao nhiêu lớp đấy
ngoại mình sẽ cập nhật lại số lượng đúng
ạ thi cái này cái này thì ra là nó lại
dễ ở điểm là khi các bạn hãy hiểu cái
này
Ừ thì các bạn có làm việc phải đi lấy
không ạ Có nhiên đi lấy thì nó sẽ rồi đó
ạ
chứ không phải tạo ra một bảng y mà cái
câu c nách 7 Nó gần như là nó đã biến
thành một cái bảng rồi không không gọi
dùng từ tạo bạn nữa bị nó không hẳn là
đúng nếu cậu bạn đấy nó không tồn tại
tồn tại lâu ấy
à à
Ừ đúng rồi cái câu select cái câu select
này nó sẽ nó sẽ tạo Nó sẽ gần như là
biến nó thành một cái bạn vì gì đó để
các bạn dùng át vệ mã kiểu dáng tên cho
cả cái bàn đấy Sau đó thì các bạn cho
hoa dựa trên mạng đấy thì ra cái đoạn
này nếu mà không dám như này thì các bạn
sẽ được viết đầy đủ như này thôi không
sai như này vẫn được không thì sai cả
Nhưng mà thực là thế không tốt mà mình
thường ai mình làm cái kiểu dán như này
cho nó hợp lý hơn đó
Ừ
Ok để nói chung là bây giờ làm để đi lấy
thì cho các bạn cũng sẽ thấy nó dễ thôi
mình chụp nhé
à à
anh after Delete này vì vậy sẽ là xóa
sinh viên không ạ thì bây giờ thì các
bạn thấy là nó giờ dễ bạn trẻ đi Lexus
đây là D đây là D bây giờ d mà thereto
thế nào xong rồi sẽ thử nhé
Bây giờ là elite four sinh viên Xóa hết
toàn bộ sinh viên luôn à
Ừ ok
khi sex
anh
em mình đi sắp một đống cùng lúc nè
em rất nhiều
em lên lên lên lên này đổi hết cái này
hay đi cho mấy ông lại bảo tôi bị bịp
lên Lên này lên này đúng không ạ Cái
mười vẫn giữ nguyên Không ạ Không ạ sợ
Bây giờ thay vì Delete from sinh viên
như thế này nếu lại bảo là ok Cái này
mấy ông vẫn về nghĩ tôi bịp đây tôi thử
Xóa mỗi từ 10 que mã Lớn hơn mười đi ông
ạ Delete này
đó số lượng nó không bị hoàn toàn sửa Ok
chị ạ thì mấy ông thấy tôi còn đi vào
đấy Cái câu truy vấn cái cơ bản và lại
các bạn học đúng không ạ Nó chỉ áp dụng
cho việc in sơ hoặc Delete
11 bản ghi một lúc thôi đúng ạ
Ừ ông kia nãy giờ cứ để cập về robot
robot và về trên sân mà đúng ạ
thì buổi sau dậy nha đấy Đúng kiểu hôm
nay chỉ học chữ cơ thể học đúng rồi bạn
ạ bây giờ đến cái phức tạp hơn một tí ở
đó là
cơ xăng update update thì như thế nào
đúng
em tắt thì bạn chất là các bạn sẽ ôm cả
Insert và Delete này thì sẽ tạo được
update thôi đúng không Nói là như thế
thôi nhưng mình từng nói gì ạ update và
bản chất là nó kết hợp yz + Delete mà nó
không ạ thì các bạn cũng sẽ làm chị cơ
như thế đúng không còn sẽ là chị thơ cả
yzk bên cái sắc thật mà đi thật làm được
300 nãy giờ làm trên nhiều bạn đi mà
đang nói là một cái vụ cơ bản vừa nãy
các bạn học đấy thì áp dụng trị đúng rồi
chị cho một bạn ghi thôi ông ạ
à Tôi đang nói vụ là nãy giờ là học xong
đúng mượn chiếc cờ after
còn chị girl instead of cơ ạ instead of
nó mới là cái Khoai buổi sau học buổi
sau hôm nay chính ở Xương vì sau mình sẽ
dạy các bạn với ý sơ lược và kết hợp cả
trên sân nữa thì ra bữa hôm nay các bạn
mà về làm bài tập lại cái làm đúng mỗi
dài lại bài hôm nay thôi đâu ạ để mà các
bạn nhớ các bạn hình dung hiểu thì buổi
sau các bạn cũng sẽ quen dần và gái kiểu
cho dụng các thứ với bạn ý rất thực và
đĩa cực các bạn làm cái in sẽ được rất
là 2a à à
xe tải kiến thức hôm nay Chị được thế
thôi nghe có dễ không dễ mà khó gì đâu
ừ ừ
chị xem hôm nay còn chia sẻ thì nghĩ anh
nhỉ
Ừ ok
Thực ra cũng chẳng còn gì chia sẻ đâu
rồi ông ạ Tôi định chia sẻ này nhưng mà
tôi định chia sẻ ở bên cái
khóa học web cơ Thế nên chắc là thôi Hôm
nay thấy hơi quá tải rồi
nên chắc là bạn cho mấy ông ngừng để mà
Thì khi làm bài tập nữa
Ừ nếu không Đừng có nước đến chân mới
nhảy nhé đến Không phải ạ Có ông vừa nãy
nửa nửa tiếng 1 tiếng trước mới ngồi làm
bài tập của tôi sẽ sẵn hôm sau không làm
được gì đâu
à à chia sẻ cách đoán con gái thích ăn
gì không ạ Không có phải mỗi hình Nếu là
Đoàn Thích ăn gì thì ra nó khá là dễ cứ
toàn tôi tôi thấy thằng có vai bạn chưa
trải rồi đó là thiếu kiểu là Ừ thì cứ
thực đố lại con gái là đâu Em biết
anh sắp dẫn em đi ăn món gì Thôi bạn con
cá trả lời trả lời cái gì thì mình cho
đi ăn cái đấy xong nhưng mà còn việc để
mặt đoán xem thực sự còn lại đang nghĩ
gì hay con gái thật sự thật
em đang muốn gì thì ra đó là khó của đôi
khi con gái nó đang biết mình muốn gì cả
Thế nên là cái tốt nhất ở đây đó là ông
phải luôn cầm cương ông vậy luôn
đoán trước được là em hãy sẽ nghĩ gì nếu
mà ông làm được thuế thì ông đúng kiểu
nhà tiên tri còn nếu mà ông làm theo
kiểu khó hơn à Dễ nhầm dễ hơn không đoán
được nó sẽ nghĩ gì thì mình chơi cho cắt
đó là nghị ghét nó ăn cái thứ mình muốn
anh đưa như là nói thế hơi quá Nhưng mà
thực là con gái về cơ bản thì tôi thấy
con gái dễ mà Chứ anh ấy mà đấy với điều
kiện nhé
em cầm cương cầm vôlăng nữa thức các
kiểu tự mình điều khiển kể cái mối quan
hệ đấy ấy đối với tôi con trai vẫn nên
là chủ động thì
ừ ừ
ý thì cái việc
Ừ để mà ông cầm Cương được như thế thì
chắc chắn là ông phải
A phẩy có cái khẩu vị hợp mạng đấy hoặc
là khẩu vị
chị đại trà giống thiệu của tôi Tại sao
cậu lại Tôi ăn rất nhiều cái thứ kiểu
người phát âm được Kiểu thế thành ra là
tôi Mà dẫn đi ăn thì chị ăn ngon nữa cả
kiểu dễ ăn hàng ra là các bạn đấy toàn
để tôi hiểu dạng hoàn toàn thích tôi
chọn món cá Anh Tuấn thế tốt Tuân trợ
toàn gái người đi ăn những ngày quá mà
anh ấy cậu chỉ ăn ở đấy thôi cứ thế
thành thành ra là mấy ông phải thay đổi
một là học cách đoán thử xem nó sẽ nghĩ
gì hay là
thì mình phải có cái Goo nào đó xong ấy
cư cứ bắt mấy bạn này ăn
không phải là ăn mấy thứ mấy Bạn ấy ghét
hay mới món bạn dị ứng là được không ạ
Ừ nhưng mà đương nhiên hội Huế Hồi đấy
tôi Thỉnh thoảng tôi cũng chán biết ăn
gì kiểu hôm trước ăn xương món đấy rồi
thì mới ông cũng phải lên cái danh sách
xô ngồi lại giống như tôi tôi làm tôn để
mà ngẫu nhiên mấy cái món chủ định - 7
món chưa đi đúng kéo ăn mấy món trong
tuần này là ăn đúng không ạ Mấy ông
Insert vào trong db2 lại đúng không yên
sẽ ở đây b là hôm nay ăn món cơm hôm sau
thì sẽ ở loại trừ đi trong vòng 7 ngày
loại mấy cái món mà ăn xong 7 ngày xong
rồi select random Prado những cái món
còn lại chẳng đời ông ông sẽ có một bảng
danh sách món ăn ngon và một bả bạn là
hôm nay ăn gì à
để mà ông lưu lại việc hôm nay ăn
abc.xyz đúng không ạ sau đó thì ông chỉ
việc là
select loại bỏ trong cái bảng
loại bỏ trong cái bào mà hôm hôm nay đã
ăn món gì trong vòng 7 ngày thế là xong
à à
anh bao kết hợp với kiến thức đã học đi
Mày không phải làm ra những cái đơn giản
thì đi đúng không ạ đi
à à
ờ ờ thì đấy tôi bảo rồi Chuẩn chuẩn Bởi
vì tôi chả trải nghiệm nhiều rồi đấy
đúng không ạ
Ẩm Thực ra là nếu anh còn hỏi thêm kiến
thức thì không nghỉ à
Ừ đúng rồi con gái hay con trai cầm
cương thật ra không quan trọng quan
trọng và đừng nghĩ ai ở bề trên của ai
mà mà tí tôi là kiểu chắc chắn nó phải
có một người chủ động
hai người chủ động thì nó mới dễ to anh
ấy người này cũng muốn ăn ở nhà hàng này
người kia 15 cửa nhà hàng kia không nên
như thế nên có một người chủ động nếu mà
con gái mà chủ động thì tôi K Ông chẳng
cần phải đến lượt hỏi nó ăn món gì nó sẽ
tự làm hoặc nó sẽ tự mua cho ông còn nếu
mà mua khi mà họ ông đã phải hỏi cô đấy
Ông là người chủ động đúng không Bác là
người chủ động thì ông không hẳn ở chủ
động hỏi mà ông ông cựu Chủ động dẫn nó
đi làm luôn chứ
anh đúng không Đừng có hỏi ông đương
nhiên là hỏi thử cái lọng tốt theo cơ ạ
Ừ nghe có vẻ tấm mí đấy nhưng ngày nào
cũng hỏi giống như kiểu thực sự thì ông
ấy biến thành một thằng không tâm lý gì
cả theo kiểu là chẳng biết được nó sẽ
nghĩ gì nên vẻ hỏi
anh nói thẳng là như thế
chị thay vì như thế kiểu tôi tôi đi hẹn
hò với mấy bạn mà cái tôi còn chưa quen
bao giờ đóng học Buổi Hẹn Đầu Tiên ý Thì
lúc ấy tôi làm gì có biết được bạn đấy
thích ăn món gì đúng không ạ Chị hỏi là
em dị ứng món gì Em biết món gì cho nó
thì hướng dẫn đi ăn những cái món mình
thích vào những cái quán mà mình cảm
thấy à Nhiều người ăn được Thành ra Cuối
cùng thì mấy bạn ấy mê tôi đường để mà
tán gái nhanh cũng một phần là đường dạ
dày đấy nhá Thế nên là mấy ông mấy ông
ghi điểm một là dẫn được đến quán ngon
hai em ấy tự nấu những cái món quán ngon
và những quán mà kiểu ít người biết nữa
thì càng tốt theo đúng kiểu là em đấy
chị nhớ mỗi mình ông thôi I
A Gọi nãy giờ chia sẻ mấy cái còn nhạy
cảm quá không biết được vì sau tố cáo
kênh ấy không em
à à
à Tại mấy bạn gái ở đây chả là xác nhận
cho tôi nói đúng này
à à
khi mình ăn mình chả không thuật toán
rồi mình còn chưa có thuật toán mình
mình nhắc đến toán được cái là bây giờ
nhắc tính toán sớm đấy ạ
à à
Ừ ok Nói chung là bây giờ hết câu hỏi
của mấy ông phải không ạ Thì bây giờ
mình xin phép nghỉ nhé Cũng mà không một
tiếng thôi Tí tôi
3 bài tập thủy sản làm lại bài hôm nay
thôi vừa hôm sau cũng sẽ đổ làm sao sẽ
học về cái khó chắc là buổi sau nữa thì
mới thành buổi cuối được sẽ học và zoom
ừ ừ
anh nói cho các bạn nhé